jack is up next
jack is in Missouri hey Jack how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call
Dave and dr. John I'm excited to talk to
you guys so I just got a big Commission
check for about $120,000 I'm waiting on
that that's after taxes how often does
the sound I've made it happen in a
couple of times but right now I'm on
baby step six and I have a really big
mortgage by myself it's a five hundred
thousand dollar house I so I'm not
calling with bad problems but then what
I notice is the more money I make and
the more I kind of worry I don't know
what that is
yeah biggie smalls talked about that
years ago or height no money more profit
anyone yeah and I feel like I already
kind of have OCD in certain ways and I
feel like it's getting to be a problem
almost but really here's where I'm at I
just got this big check on my baby
sticks baby step six
and I owe about 370,000 on my mortgage
so I'm uh I'm above about a hundred and
twenty thousand in equity right now so I
was thinking I could sell my house right
now I can get rid of baby step six by
maybe building something small or just
going and downsizing so what do you
think about that plan does that sound
something like you would do I make
enough money about 200,000 a year right
now and I'm in sales so that kind of
swings with the economy so I'm a little
worried there that I could find myself
in trouble in a year with the points of
kind of dollar mortgage by myself so how
much is in your emergency fund so right
now I have about one hundred and thirty
thousand in the bank so my emergency
fund kind of skipped that step because I
built that with that big commission
check immediately and I've always
wondered your emergency fund to be I
feel comfortable would say thirty
thousand okay means you have a hundred
thousand dollars extra I don't baby step
six right yeah yeah and
all on top of this I just got out of
prison ten years ago I was in prison for
about two years I got no fist fight when
I was a young man no weapons or anything
like that you used but he was in the
military so I really got I really got in
trouble for it so I feel like I'm also a
success story and I don't I've never
really shared that with anyone like
employers anything like that something I
really keep secret but I also feel like
it's something that should be talked
about like people should celebrate that
but I also feel ashamed of it it's it's
a lot to ask but really am I on that
track would you sell the house go
something small because I have a pretty
extravagant house for a single man so
old are you I just turned 36 what kind
of house do you want to own when you're
42 you know I like nice things I sell a
nice product from how and
a building product I just feel like
something else hold up
what kind of house that you want to live
in when you're 42 just something like a
ranch 89 square feet that's nice and
that's a lot less than what you have now
five twenty five hundred square feet
it's a little big this Jack this isn't a
square footage issue man you're gonna
have to you're gonna have to make peace
with who you were and the success and
the man that you are now and you're
gonna have to make peace with the fact
that you're good at your job
and you make good money and you have a
heart for helping people and I want you
to go out and help people but this isn't
a house size issue and this is a demon
that that you can't exercise about
running from it and you can't come up
with a new plan a new scheme you're
gonna have to come at peace with Jack
you make $200,000 a year you live in a
$500,000 house there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that right see I do
feel like maybe it's too much for myself
so okay that does feel better but does
it feel like you so much I mean the
difference in 2,500 square feet in 1,800
square feet in terms of too much houses
it's over too much space yeah that's one
rec room I mean there's not that's not a
you know
you know are you having problems with
deserving you think or worse yeah
absolutely
always you know it's a shame I guess
it's shame it just it's hard to get rid
of it I don't think you can get a small
enough house to get rid of that as soon
as you buy a small house and it's gonna
be nice you're gonna work on a scheme
and then you're gonna have to make
another plan and another move another
thing and you work your baby step 6
yeah pay off your house man give some
away when's the last time you got in a
fistfight
I actually got paid to do it
professionally
well besides professional fighting you
what I mean Oh since I was named the kid
you know you're not that guy anymore
and for for probably a hundred reasons
all valid you're letting that guy still
drive the car that you get to and from
work every day in and whether that's
going to see a counselor whether that's
gonna see a pastor whether that's
whatever that has to be you need to do
the work that it's going to take and it
can be easy and quick it's gonna be
painful but easy and quick and get that
guy at the driver's seat maybe a really
good exercise for you to keep this house
which is gonna make you deal with this
crap I think that's a good idea and
you're gonna you're gonna be OCD and
you're gonna get stupid thing paid off
in about three years anyway so I'm not
worried about the debt on the thing you
know but I mean you're gonna you're
gonna walk in there every day and go I
own this house and I'm gonna have to
deal with this stuff and he's got to
look in the mirror and say I am NOT my
yesterday exactly Thanks well that's
what I mean I am I right now this house
makes you deserve it yeah yeah and it
makes you face it you're deserving yeah
you're good man dude you got a really
good heart and a good story and a really
good story and you will tell this story
someday
hmm there'll be a venue there'll be a
time and it will inspire other young men
that have bumped into stuff that follows
them around and in Dave I think this is
important to point out for folks who are
struggling folks who have made a dumb
decision folks who are still
wrestling with digging himself out of
whatever hole they got shoved into or or
jumped into themselves economic success
winning won't make you well I guess is
the best way to say that being at the
top of your chain getting a on top of a
200k salary which is ridiculous awesome
getting the just another flyby $120,000
check doesn't make that go away right
you can't run from it half million
dollar house doesn't make that go away
you got to do the hard work with being
okay with who you are when you see in
the mirror you know I when we went broke
my need for stuff got fried out of me
yeah I mean to where I'm just stuff
stuff and I like nice things I've got
some nice things but my need for stuff
to the point that I was driving a junky
car and I had plenty of money yeah and a
buddy of mine we were going to
Chattanooga and the car blew radiator
we're on the way Chattanooga and we're
on the side of the road and I was a
millionaire again and I'm on the road in
a junky car and my buddy is like you're
an idiot
mm-hmm I'm like what I don't need a
better car yes yes you do we're on the
side of the road the famous songwriter
theologian rich Mullen said people can
be as proud of the things they don't
have as people are of the things they do
have yeah it's the same art it had it
had it was a healing thing for me to go
buy me a decent car because you got it
done with more than easily could afford
by then and and I've gotten over that
now Dave will always have some cars now
and just because somebody said I
shouldn't have them that that
immediately went I need to go get them
so but it's amazing how that hangs are
on your neck from when you're a kid or
from an incident like this idea that I'm
not worth that I'm not I'm not well how
it looks like don't do that bro who
needs a car like that right no one needs
a house like that was that jesus would
have driven an old accord or something
whatever it is cuz they're gonna be one
old Honda because everybody's in one
Accord that's right that's right
but the
1994 Camry anything above that your
salvation is in issue you know so yeah
there's that stuff right and it's just
as craziness very interesting huh good
for Jack man you're a good man you're
worth it you're a good man keep your
house and pay it off
I'll see what I would do if I were in
your shoes heal your heart I had to get
a car you got to get a house this is the
Dave Ramsey show